[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul and everyone's dancing in
the moonlight with the release of a ton
of new trailers and tv spots throughout
this video we're going to be breaking
down all the brand new looks and talking
about the hidden details what they
confirm and also the easter eggs that
are hiding in them i promise not to sing
any more and with the show being over
just one week away this will be our
final theories video before releases
next week i'm really hyped for it and i
want to just get right into it with the
featurette that was released last week
i am
stephen
the way we're tackling the story we
learn about stephen and then learn about
mark what's wrong with you mark
why did you call me
they're the same person
the tone is like fight club meets
indiana jones it's a bit dark at times
to tie it into something so vast and
supernatural it's amazing
okay so as it's been stated the series
is going to show things from the
perspective of steven grant and we'll
watch as he learns about the other side
of his persona called mark specter this
kind of goes against the grain as in the
comics it was mark that was the dominant
personality and after he was introduced
in werewolf by night 32 we slowly
started to learn about his backstory
mark was the son of a rabbi who came to
view his father as a coward because he
fled from germany during world war ii in
order to escape the holocaust because of
this he trained to become a mercenary
and this eventually led him on a mission
to an archaeological dig out in egypt
betrayed by one of the soldiers who went
out there with him mark was left at
death's door and it's here that he came
across the target of the dig the shrine
of konshu mark promised to become the
gods avatar on earth and he ended up
wrapping himself in conscious shroud
which came to be his costume after he
returned to america mark created several
personas including stephen grant and
also jake lockley the former of which
was a playboy he used his connections
with the elite to gain intel whereas the
latter was a cab driver who kept his ear
to the streets over the decades this
evolved into taking on a more
psychological aspect and mark was
diagnosed with d.i.d or dissociative
identity disorder this ended up creating
completely offshoot personalities within
him that all wrestle for control and the
fight club analogy is used to basically
show that he's a lot like tyler duden
which i shouldn't really mention cause
yeah first rule of fight club now we
know from interviews that the show is
also meant to be based heavily around
memento and in case you haven't seen it
it's basically a film about a man who
has no short term memory and we watches
the entire movie plays out in reverse
chronological order all of the scenes
happen with the one that should follow
it actually being shown to us beforehand
and because of this we kind of learn the
truth about what's really going on now i
don't think that the series will do that
but instead i believe that we'll start
off with stephen working his mundane job
in a museum which is where he'll be
introduced to arthur harrow and konchu
who appears to be stalking the character
he'll unlikely find mark's phone in his
home and this will be when he starts to
remember his time as the character which
will fill in his egyptian origin story
steven
you weren't supposed to see any of this
what are you you sure you want to know
am i like some sort of secret agent
it's a little more complicated than that
now i kind of think that this is
confirmed as we find stephen and what
looks to be a lockup and in a reflection
we can't catch mark explaining exactly
what's happening steven finds a gun as
well as an american passport with mark's
name on it steven is judging by the
accent he's bloody cockney and therefore
him having an american accent it's
pretty shocking to say the least thank
you thank you thank you very much and
the oscar isaacs goes too
anyway i think this is likely him
unearthing the truth about mark and
discovering a room full of his
belongings that helps him to fill in the
blanks on exactly what's going on it's
also what appears to be a golden scarab
in here and the wings on its spring open
i'm guessing that mark got this on his
trip to egypt and will kind of segue
from here into learning about his time
out there we do seen one of the trailer
shots that ethan hawkes arthur harrow
has it levitating in his hand almost
like a compass so this might be the
mcguffin that they're all after now this
bag seems to be quite important and if
you look at the trailers namely the
point where mark is chased by kunchu he
appears to also be carrying it i've got
no idea what it's got in it but it's
going to be interesting to see how this
factors into everything and why both
stephen and the god are desperate to get
it now we're yet to be shown jake in any
of the teasers and to keep things simple
i think that they might focus things
solely on mark and steven it's possible
that these two sides end up getting
their own moonlight costumes and this
could actually be hinted at in the tv
spots during one shot we see where the
character appears to be in the mr knight
costume this was recently introduced in
the comics and it's much more of a
sophisticated persona i would say
recently probably like 10 years ago but
2020 has just been never ending however
from here he transforms in the more
typical looking version of the suit and
i think that this might be during a
scene in which steven passes over
control to mark and the costume warps
around him hints of this control going
back and forth seemed to be going on
during the van chase scene that we see
play out and at one point steven's eyes
flick up almost like he's in rem sleep
there is a major focus on dreams in the
teasers and we watched as stephen has
tied himself to the bed put lines of
sign around where he sleeps and also
place tape over the doors so he can see
if anyone's opened it i think the whole
idea of the day night song will also
have been chosen for this specific
reason
[Music]
stevie stephen
potentially steven is the persona he
takes on during the day and then it's at
night which is when he switches to mark
now if you're going to let me reach for
a second it could also be playing on the
phrase night and day which means two
complete opposite things this could be
represented in stephen and mark because
one is an american secret agent rasa the
lovely he's a lovely cockney bloke a
shiny shoes governor now mirrors are
used throughout the teasers as well and
we have the reflection in the water as
stephen walks into the museum the one in
the bathroom when he transforms and also
the one in his home when he sees that
his face is badly bruised beyond this
the thesis and trailers are absolutely
littered with reflective surfaces and
there's even a point where we can see
steven's reflection remaining behind in
the museum class they're clearly playing
with the idea of the two personalities
going back and forth in mirrors and i
think it's going to be really
interesting to see as they battle out
not only with the bad guys but also
themselves now if you're enjoying the
video so far then hit that thumbs up
button yeah and make sure you subscribe
as we're going to be covering the show
every single week this is in a pyramid
scheme and you're in denial if you think
our egypt puns smell bad enough to make
pharaoh moan
what's a an egyptian's favorite
chocolate
ferro rocher oh moving on
every aspect of this show has a duality
and we've shifted the paradigm
for me what's really exciting is that
it's totally unpredictable
now the show seems to be taking place in
two major locations the first of which
is london and we're getting a lot of
things there such as the typical red
buses that you usually see one of these
has a grc advert on it which was heavily
discussed in falcon and the winter
soldier the global repatriation council
helped to re-home those brought back by
the blip and because of this we know
that at least the elements in london are
taking place after avengers end game the
full advert says reuniting you with your
better half which could be a play on how
half of all life was snapped away but it
may also be enough to mark and steven
speaking with each other i think the
majority of the show early on will take
place in london and that it's from here
that we'll travel to egypt which is
shown heavily in the introducing
moonlight featurette this would also
explain why mark has an american
passport as he would of course need it
for traveling a huge shout out to eric
varsity rock stars for pointing out that
the passport was created in december
2018 meaning that it happened just after
the snap which took place earlier that
year i think it would be so cool if we
got a flashback to mark picking up his
passport when it was first made and then
we followed him out to egypt as he met
harrow for the first time harrow is
quite a mysterious character and just in
the same way that moonai is an avatar of
konshu i think arthur will be one for
another egyptian god in the comics
harold was a mad scientist that made a
handful of appearances in the 1980s and
it looks like they've completely changed
things up so we can't really guess at
what's going on in the show like we we'd
be able to with an established character
just like mephisto now ethan hawk has
stated in interviews that he's very much
like a david koresh type character which
does give us a hint towards what could
be going on in real life quresh was a
cult leader that claimed to be a prophet
sent by god and harrow could be doing
this in the name of an egyptian one now
in the teasers there's several images of
crocodiles throughout and not only did
one appear on mark's farm background but
it also seems like harrow has two
crocodile head tattoos there are two
possibilities over who this could be
with the first being sebek the crocodile
god however there's also amit who's
known as the devourer of souls i think
that it'll more likely be them amid
actually appeared in the comics during
the jeff lemire run and it posed as a
psychologist called dr emmett this took
place in a psychiatric hospital called
mercy hospital for the mentally ill he
was very much in the same vein as the
opening of 12 monkeys with his staff
attempting to convince mark that his
life as moonlight was a fantasy and that
the ward was where he'd been since he
was a kid over time he broke through the
illusion and discovered that it was
actually located in a vessel outside of
time and space known as the other voigt
the graphic novel that collects this run
is absolutely brilliant and it has some
fourth wall breaking moments such as
mark transforming into steven who's an
actor on a tv show called moonlight we
jump to that and basically see things
all play out from behind the scenes of a
set and then when they shout action and
start filming we're back with mark
watching it play out for real now i
think it might be amit is because in
that run emmett sends her orderlies
after mark when he tries to escape and
these are revealed to be jackals if you
cast your mind back to the trailer
you'll remember that mark was bashing
one out in a bathroom
like not like not bashing it out like
that and everyone including you thought
it was a werewolf well kevin bloody
spoilers said it was a jackal and we can
see in the new tv spots that one jumps
after moonlight in it i'm guessing that
this is the one he fights in the
bathroom and then it chases him through
the night definitely a jackal i don't
want to hear any of this werewolf talk
and maybe next time you're listening to
your daft old uncle kevin's spoilers eh
also that's maria rambo in the doctor
strange trailer i'm telling you [ __ ] off
with the jonathan mages kang theories
you stupid [ __ ] [ __ ]
anyway an interesting shot that links to
the aforementioned graphic novel comes
when we see mark inside what appears to
be a psychiatric ward and he's banging
his head i would love to see some of the
fourth wall breaking elements of this
book play on the show and it would be
crazy if they did some elements of it
where the director just yells cut and it
pulls back to show steven's just on a tv
set that would actually be the perfect
way to do a kevin foggy cameo or
something and that's what i've got my
fingers crossed for anyway that's all
the major elements of the new tv sports
uh i thought what worth talking about
sorry if i sound a bit run down got a
bit of a cold from looking after the
kids day and night hey
sorry about that pun probably probably
doing everyone's heading as well with
how much i keep talking about the kids
at every opportunity but hopefully you
enjoyed the video and if you leave a
comment you'll be entered into a
competition this month where we're
giving away three copies of spider-man
no way home all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the teasers
we picked the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one on the screen right now so if
that's you then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want someone else
to watch then make sure you check our
breakdown of all the easter eggs in
their way home which will be linked on
screen right now we go over the entire
thing from top to bottom and it's one of
our best videos yet the people online in
the comments they say it's the best and
i bloody believed them although thanks
for sitting through this video i've been
poor let's see in the next one take care
peace